Katrina: （歌词）故事的小黄花
Katrina: (Lyrics) The little yellow flower of the story
Shure: （歌词）小黄花从出生那年就飘着
Shure: (Lyrics) The little yellow flower has been floating since the year it was born
Katrina: （歌词）从生那年就飘着童年的倒擦肩
Katrina: (Lyrics) Since the year I was born, childhood memories have been passing by
Shure: （歌词）童年的荡秋千随
Shure: (Lyrics) Swinging in the childhood swing
Katrina: （歌词）随记忆一直晃到现在没说
Katrina: (Lyrics) Memories have been swaying till now without saying a word
Katrina: （歌词）风吹着琴奏望着天空
Katrina: (Lyrics) The wind blows, the piano plays, looking at the sky
Katrina: （歌词）想起花瓣时时凋落
Katrina: (Lyrics) Thinking of the petals that fall from time to time
Katrina: （歌词）为你唱歌的那一天我
Katrina: (Lyrics) The day I sang for you
Shure: （歌词）那一天花落的那一天
Shure: (Lyrics) The day the flowers fell
Shure: （歌词）教室的那一间
Shure: (Lyrics) In that classroom
Katrina: （歌词）那一天怎么看不见
Katrina: (Lyrics) That day, why couldn't I see
Shure: （歌词）我怎么看不见
Shure: (Lyrics) Why couldn't I see
Shure: （歌词）消失的下雨天
Shure: (Lyrics) The rainy days that disappeared
Shure: （歌词）我好想再淋一遍
Shure: (Lyrics) I really want to get drenched again
Katrina: （歌词）好想再淋一遍
Katrina: (Lyrics) Really want to get drenched again
Shure: （歌词）没想到我失去勇气我还留着
Shure: (Lyrics) I didn't expect to lose my courage, but I still hold on
Shure: （歌词）好想再问一遍
Shure: (Lyrics) Really want to ask again
Shure: （歌词）刮风这天我试过牵着你手但偏偏
Shure: (Lyrics) On the windy day, I tried to hold your hand but
Katrina: （歌词）这天我试过握着你手
Katrina: (Lyrics) On that day, I tried to hold your hand
Katrina: （歌词）但偏偏风渐渐大到我看你不见
Katrina: (Lyrics) But the wind gradually grew so strong that I couldn't see you
Katrina: （歌词）还要多久我才能在你身边
Katrina: (Lyrics) How much longer till I can be by your side
Katrina: （歌词）有个人爱你很久
Katrina: (Lyrics) Someone has loved you for a long time
Shure: （歌词）有个人爱你很久
Shure: (Lyrics) Someone has loved you for a long time
Shure: 但偏偏风
Shure: (Lyrics) But the wind
Katrina: （歌词）但偏偏风渐渐
Katrina: (Lyrics) But the wind gradually
Shure: （歌词）渐渐吹得好远
Shure: (Lyrics) Gradually blows farther and farther away
Shure: （歌词）好不容易又能再多爱一天但故事
Shure: (Lyrics) Finally, another day to love, but the story
Katrina: 重新来
Katrina: Start over
Katrina: 买多了
Katrina: Bought too much
Katrina: 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Katrina: Dum dum dum dum dum dum dum
Katrina: （歌词）故事的小黄花
Katrina: (Lyrics) The small yellow flowers in the story
Katrina: （歌词）从出生那年就飘着
Katrina: (Lyrics) Have been floating since the year they were born
Katrina: （歌词）童年的荡秋千
Katrina: (Lyrics) The childhood swings
Shure: （歌词）随记忆一直晃到现在
Shure: (Lyrics) Have been swaying with memories till now
Katrina: （歌词）随记忆置换到现在的索索塞拉
Katrina: (Lyrics) Swaying with memories to the present, so so sa la
Shure: （歌词）东西都西拉索拉西西西西都西拉索
Shure: (Lyrics) Do re mi fa so la si do si la so
Shure: （歌词）吹着前奏望着天空
Shure: (Lyrics) Blowing the prelude, looking at the sky
Katrina: （歌词）吹着前奏望着天空
Katrina: (Lyrics) Blowing the prelude, looking at the sky
Shure: （歌词）我心里还盼着那时的凋落
Shure: (Lyrics) My heart still longs for the time of falling petals
Shure: （歌词）为你翘课的那一天
Shure: (Lyrics) The day I skipped class for you
Shure: （歌词）花落的那一天
Shure: (Lyrics) The day the flowers fell
Shure: （歌词）（歌词）教室的那一间我怎么看不见
Shure: (Lyrics) In that classroom, why couldn't I see
Shure: （歌词）消失的下雨天我好想再淋一遍
Shure: (Lyrics) Disappearing rainy days, I really want to get soaked again
Shure: （歌词）没想到我失去勇气我还留着
Shure: (Lyrics) I didn't expect that I still have the courage I lost
Shure: （歌词）好想再问一遍你会等待还是离开
Shure: (Lyrics) Really want to ask you again, will you wait or leave
Shure: （歌词）刮风这天我试过握着你手
Shure: (Lyrics) On windy days, I tried holding your hand
Katrina: （歌词）刮风这天
Katrina: (Lyrics) On windy days
Katrina: （歌词）我试过握着你手
Katrina: (Lyrics) I tried holding your hand
Shure: （歌词）但偏偏风渐渐大到我看你不见
Shure: (Lyrics) But the wind gradually grew strong, and I couldn't see you
Katrina: （歌词）还要多久
Katrina: (Lyrics) How much longer
Katrina: （歌词）我才能在你身边
Katrina: (Lyrics) Until I can be by your side
Katrina: （歌词）原谅我真的那么执着
Katrina: (Lyrics) Forgive me for being so persistent
Katrina: （歌词）我会比较好一点
Katrina: (Lyrics) I will be a little better
Katrina: （歌词）从前从前
Katrina: (Lyrics) Once upon a time
Katrina: （歌词）有个人爱你很久
Katrina: (Lyrics) There was someone who loved you for a long time
Katrina: （歌词）但但偏偏风渐渐大到我看你不见
Katrina: (Lyrics) But the wind gradually grew strong, and I couldn't see you
Katrina: （歌词）还要多久
Katrina: (Lyrics) How much longer
Katrina: （歌词）我才能在你身边
Katrina: (Lyrics) Until I can be by your side
Katrina: （歌词）等到那天
Katrina: (Lyrics) Wait until that day
Shure: 太棒了我们无敌了
Shure: That was awesome, we are unbeatable
Shure: 简直就是小周杰伦啊
Shure: You're like a little Jay Chou
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Katrina: 贪恋几遍
Katrina: Indulge a few more times
Katrina: 啊还是平的爽
Katrina: Ah, it's still fun when it's flat
Katrina: 开这种平的爽啊
Katrina: Driving this flat one is fun
Shure: 我那个大的
Shure: My big one
Katrina: 这个这会不会强迫症受不了
Katrina: This might be unbearable for OCD
Katrina: 我是能接受
Katrina: I can accept it
Katrina: 算了都搞成这样吧
Katrina: Forget it, let's just do it like this
Katrina: 啊这下面还有两坨
Katrina: Ah, there are two lumps down here
Katrina: 这跟搁屎一样怎么
Katrina: This looks like poop, how come
Katrina: （歌词）故事的小黄花从出生那年就飘
Katrina: (Lyrics) The little yellow flower in the story has been floating since the year it was born
Katrina: （歌词）秋天的荡秋千随记忆
Katrina: (Lyrics) The swing in autumn follows the memories
Shure: （歌词）for me
Shure: (Lyrics) For me
Katrina: （歌词）我爱你
Katrina: (Lyrics) I love you
Shure: （歌词）nothing just time
Shure: (Lyrics) Nothing just time
Shure: （歌词）follow my lead
Shure: (Lyrics) Follow my lead
Katrina: （歌词）i found a girl beautiful and free
Katrina: (Lyrics) I found a girl beautiful and free
Shure: （歌词）find a girl
Shure: (Lyrics) Find a girl
Shure: （歌词）beautiful thing
Shure: (Lyrics) Beautiful thing
Shure: 你
Shure: You
Shure: （歌词）i never knew you i never knew you were someone waiting for me
Shure: (Lyrics) I never knew you, I never knew you were someone waiting for me
Shure: （歌词）we were just kids when we fell in love
Shure: (Lyrics) we were just kids when we fell in love
Shure: （歌词）not knowing what what it was na na na
Shure: (Lyrics) not knowing what what it was na na na
Shure: （歌词）too too much
Shure: (Lyrics) too too much
Katrina: 嗯但是好香啊
Katrina: Hmm, but it smells so good.
Shure: 卧槽这个变道夹彻底不行了
Shure: Damn, this lane change clip is completely useless now.
Shure: 你看他已经夹不紧了
Shure: Look, it can't hold tight anymore.
Katrina: 老了
Katrina: It's old.
Shure: 不中用
Shure: Useless.
Shure: （歌词）found a lie
Shure: (Lyrics) found a lie
Shure: （歌词）for me
Shure: (Lyrics) for me
Shure: （歌词）darling just time
Shure: (Lyrics) darling just time
Shure: （歌词）祈祷拥有一颗透明的心灵
Shure: (Lyrics) Praying for a transparent heart
Shure: （歌词）和会流泪的眼睛
Shure: (Lyrics) and eyes that can cry
Shure: （歌词）哦给你再去相信的勇气
Shure: (Lyrics) oh give you the courage to believe again
Katrina: （歌词）勇气哦越过谎言去拥抱你
Katrina: (Lyrics) courage to embrace you beyond the lies
Shure: （歌词）哦越过谎言去拥抱你
Shure: (Lyrics) oh beyond the lies to embrace you
Shure: （歌词）每当我找不到存在的意义
Shure: (Lyrics) whenever I can't find the meaning of existence
Katrina: （歌词）每当我找不到存在的意义
Katrina: (Lyrics) whenever I can't find the meaning of existence
Shure: （歌词）每当我迷失在黑夜里
Shure: (Lyrics) whenever I'm lost in the dark night
Katrina: （歌词）每当我迷失在黑夜里
Katrina: (Lyrics) whenever I'm lost in the dark night
Shure: （歌词）哦夜空中最亮的星请你指引我前行
Shure: (Lyrics) oh brightest star in the night sky, please guide me forward
Katrina: （歌词）哦夜空中最亮的星请指引我前行
Katrina: (Lyrics) oh brightest star in the night sky, please guide me forward
Shure: freestyle吗
Shure: Freestyle?
Katrina: 不会还没有修炼
Katrina: I can't, haven't practiced.
Katrina: 修炼到那个程度
Katrina: Haven't practiced to that level.
Shure: 可以来段说唱这叫
Shure: You can try a bit of rap, it's called
Katrina: 我我吗呵呵
Katrina: Me? Haha.
Katrina: 菜多
Katrina: Too many dishes.
Katrina: 唉
Katrina: Sigh.
Shure: 看随便套一个说唱词
Shure: Look, just use any rap lyrics.
Shure: 这样就可以
Shure: That'll work.
Katrina: 天
Katrina: Oh my.
Katrina: 好难搭配啊
Katrina: So hard to match.
Shure: 比如说
Shure: For example,
Shure: 想想有什么说唱
Shure: Think of some rap lyrics.
Shure: 你平常喜欢的rapper都有哪些
Shure: Which rappers do you usually like?
Katrina: 马思维和沙一汀
Katrina: Ma Siwei and Sha Yiting.
Shure: 就随便套一个他的
Shure: Just use any of their lyrics.
Shure: 所以你睡了没好吧
Shure: So, are you asleep? Fine.
Shure: 想想词什么的
Shure: Think of some lyrics or something.
Katrina: （歌词）所以你睡了没
Katrina: (Lyrics) So, are you asleep?
Shure: 完全感受这种小清新的感觉
Shure: Totally feeling this fresh vibe.
Katrina: 我不记得词了
Katrina: I don't remember the lyrics.
Katrina: release
Katrina: Release.
Shure: （歌词）出门多久没有拉开窗帘
Shure: (Lyrics) How long has it been since you opened the curtains?
Shure: （歌词）多久没有出门
Shure: (Lyrics) How long has it been since you went out?
Shure: （歌词）多久没有拉
Shure: (Lyrics) How long has it been?
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Shure: （歌词）多久没有出门
Shure: (Lyrics) How long has it been since you went out?
Shure: （歌词）多久没有拉开窗帘
Shure: (Lyrics) How long has it been since you opened the curtains?
Shure: （歌词）感到清晨这段时间可能哒哒哒
Shure: (Lyrics) Feeling the morning, maybe da da da.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Shure: （歌词）多久没有出门
Shure: (Lyrics) How long has it been since you went out?
Shure: （歌词）多久没有拉着窗帘
Shure: (Lyrics) How long has it been since you pulled the curtains?
Shure: （歌词）看到清晨这段时间
Shure: (Lyrics) Seeing the morning.
Shure: （歌词）特别特别特别特别的清晨
Shure: (Lyrics) Especially, especially, especially, especially the morning.
Shure: （歌词）你把爱和删掉
Shure: (Lyrics) You remove love.
Shure: （歌词）撕掉你的空投指标
Shure: (Lyrics) Tear off your airdrop indicator.
Shure: （歌词）跟着哒哒哒哒
Shure: (Lyrics) Follow da da da da.
Shure: （歌词）知道答案是这次睡了没
Shure: (Lyrics) Know the answer is this time, are you asleep?
Shure: （歌词）所以你睡了没
Shure: (Lyrics) So, are you asleep?
Katrina: 哼
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: （歌词）所以你睡了没
Shure: (Lyrics) So, are you asleep?
Shure: （歌词）你有好多久没有出门坐上门
Shure: (Lyrics) How long has it been since you went out and sat at the door?
Shure: （歌词）又拉开窗帘看到那个清晨
Shure: (Lyrics) And opened the curtains to see that morning?
Shure: （歌词）这段时间喝了太多啤酒
Shure: (Lyrics) During this time, drank too much beer.
Shure: （歌词）和你分开之后我的天都塌了
Shure: (Lyrics) After breaking up with you, my world collapsed.
Shure: （歌词）没有动力过的没有精神啊
Shure: (Lyrics) No motivation, no energy.
Shure: （歌词）不管那里是什么样的天气
Shure: (Lyrics) No matter what the weather is like.
Shure: （歌词）怎样丢掉了这个你不该有的吸引力
Shure: (Lyrics) How to get rid of this unnecessary attraction?
Shure: （歌词）和你我都雪亮
Shure: (Lyrics) We are both clear.
Shure: （歌词）从不向人展示岸的那面
Shure: (Lyrics) Never show the other side of the shore to others.
Shure: （歌词）所以你睡了没
Shure: (Lyrics) So, are you asleep?
Shure: 是不是就是这个感觉了
Shure: Is this the feeling?
Katrina: 完全变一个风格还有
Katrina: Completely changes the style, and...
Katrina: 你拿算了
Katrina: You just take it.
Katrina: 你听过没
Katrina: Have you heard it?
Katrina: （歌词）不知道算是谁的错
Katrina: (Lyrics) Don't know whose fault it is.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: （歌词）两个人的话
Katrina: (Lyrics) If it's just the two of us
Shure: 这叫冷战吗
Shure: Is this called a cold war?
Katrina: 哦冷哦对
Katrina: Oh, cold war, right.
Katrina: 搞混了TT的冷战
Katrina: Mixed up TT's cold war.
Shure: 冷战时聪明女人的做法什么鬼
Shure: What's with the smart woman's approach during a cold war?
Katrina: 这是巨难用
Katrina: This is really hard to use.
Katrina: 我还买了10个
Katrina: I even bought 10 of them.
Katrina: 新号
Katrina: New account.
Shure: 居然真的有吉他谱这个东西
Shure: There really is such a thing as guitar tabs.
Katrina: 不如我直接贴明信片吧
Katrina: I'd rather just paste postcards.
Katrina: 感觉这东西做的
Katrina: Feels like this thing is made...
Shure: （歌词）算是谁的错
Shure: (Lyrics) Whose fault is it
Shure: （歌词）两个人变得话不多
Shure: (Lyrics) The two of us talk less and less
Katrina: （歌词）两个人变得话不多
Katrina: (Lyrics) The two of us talk less and less
Shure: （歌词）气氛尴尬但不戳破
Shure: (Lyrics) The awkward atmosphere but we don't break it
Katrina: （歌词）尴尬不戳破就得过且过
Katrina: (Lyrics) Awkward but we don't break it, just let it slide
Shure: （歌词）都得过且过
Shure: (Lyrics) We just let it slide
Katrina: 我去拿俩明信片
Katrina: I'll go get two postcards.
Shure: （歌词）当发现互相都在躲
Shure: (Lyrics) When we realize we're both avoiding
Shure: （歌词）伤人的话都不想说
Shure: (Lyrics) Don't want to say hurtful words
Shure: （歌词）拿什么跟你作比较才算特
Shure: (Lyrics) What can I compare you to that makes it special
Katrina: （歌词）算特别对你的感觉强烈
Katrina: (Lyrics) To make it special, my feelings for you are strong
Shure: （歌词）别对你的感觉强烈
Shure: (Lyrics) My feelings for you are strong
Shure: （歌词）却又不太了解
Shure: (Lyrics) Yet I don't quite understand
Katrina: （歌词）却却又不太了解
Katrina: (Lyrics) Yet I don't quite understand
Katrina: （歌词）只凭直觉
Katrina: (Lyrics) Just going by intuition
Katrina: （歌词）你像窝在被子里的舒服
Katrina: (Lyrics) You feel like the comfort of being wrapped in a blanket
Katrina: （歌词）却又像风捉摸不住
Katrina: (Lyrics) Yet you're like the wind, hard to grasp
Shure: （歌词）像手腕上散发的香水味
Shure: (Lyrics) Like the scent of perfume on the wrist
Katrina: （歌词） 像手腕上散发的香水味
Katrina: (Lyrics) Like the scent of perfume on the wrist
Shure: （歌词）像爱不释手的
Shure: (Lyrics) Like something you can't put down
Katrina: （歌词）像爱不爱不释手的
Katrina: (Lyrics) Like something you can't put down
Shure: （歌词）红色高跟鞋
Shure: (Lyrics) Red high heels
Shure: （歌词）如此生活30年
Shure: (Lyrics) Living like this for 30 years
Shure: 这样的一个和弦进行可以唱好多歌
Shure: This kind of chord progression can be used for many songs.
Shure: 就是456进行
Shure: It's the 4-5-6 progression.
Shure: 再比如说那个d调的卡农
Shure: For example, the Canon in D major.
Shure: （歌词）是的我看见到处是阳光
Shure: (Lyrics) Yes, I see sunlight everywhere
Katrina: （歌词）到处是阳光
Katrina: (Lyrics) Sunlight everywhere
Shure: （歌词）快乐在城市上空在城市上空飘荡
Shure: (Lyrics) Happiness floating over the city, floating over the city
Shure: （歌词）IING happy ING
Shure: (lyrics) IING happy ING
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: （歌词）哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒
Shure: (lyrics) da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da
Katrina: 啦啦
Katrina: La la
Shure: （歌词）恋爱ING
Shure: (lyrics) Love ING
Katrina: （歌词）i n g happy I n g
Katrina: (lyrics) I N G happy I N G
Shure: （歌词）IBING哒
Shure: (lyrics) I BING da
Katrina: （歌词）黎明有你都心跳到不行
Katrina: (lyrics) Dawn with you makes my heart race
Shure: 哒哒哒哒
Shure: Da da da da
Shure: 哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒
Shure: Da da da da da da da da
Katrina: （歌词）当你抬起头
Katrina: (lyrics) When you lift your head
Katrina: （歌词）你正看向我
Katrina: (lyrics) You're looking at me
Katrina: （歌词）夜空倒映着夏夜灿烂的烟火
Katrina: (lyrics) The night sky reflects the brilliant fireworks of summer night
Katrina: （歌词）黑暗的心从此坚定永远
Katrina: (lyrics) From then on, my dark heart became steadfast forever
Katrina: 今天中午点什么外卖
Katrina: What should we order for lunch today?
Shure: 早上不是吃过了吗
Shure: Didn't we eat breakfast already?
Shure: 中午还吃吗
Shure: Are we eating lunch too?
Shure: 今天晚上就回去了
Shure: I'm going back tonight
Katrina: 谁啊
Katrina: Who?
Shure: 我
Shure: Me
Katrina: 为啥
Katrina: Why?
Shure: 我明天要回去上班了
Shure: I have to go back to work tomorrow
Katrina: 那你明天拿不到工资哦
Katrina: Then you won't get your salary tomorrow
Shure: 没办法呀
Shure: Can't be helped
Katrina: 那你今天就是完全滚蛋是吗
Katrina: So you're completely leaving today?
Shure: 对我就是这么想
Shure: Yes, that's what I think
Shure: 但还没有跟杨老板说
Shure: But I haven't told Jake yet
Shure: 然后周一上班之后
Shure: Then after starting work on Monday
Shure: 要跟leader提辞职的事情
Shure: I need to talk to the leader about resigning
Katrina: 哎呀你这变动真的唉
Katrina: Oh, this change of yours is really...
Shure: 哎
Shure: Sigh
Katrina: 摘一朵小花
Katrina: Pick a little flower
Shure: 再不提我后面还要出去玩
Shure: If I don't mention it, I still have plans to go out later
Katrina: 再不提转正了
Katrina: If you don't mention it, you'll get promoted
Shure: 那不至于
Shure: That's not likely
Shure: 转正他们不稀得要我
Shure: They wouldn't want me for the promotion
Shure: （歌词）爱上你是座欲望
Shure: (lyrics) Falling in love with you is a desire
Katrina: 看看我
Katrina: Look at me
Shure: 大石碎胸口
Shure: Crushing stone on chest
Shure: （歌词）欲望还想继续做欲望
Shure: (Lyrics) Desire still wants to continue being desire
Shure: （歌词）而爱刚已经不知去向
Shure: (Lyrics) And love has already disappeared
Shure: （歌词）此刻它最大此去与众心没有潮汐的梦
Shure: (Lyrics) At this moment it is the greatest, leaving no tides in the hearts
Shure: （歌词）胸口已暮色苍茫
Shure: (Lyrics) The chest already dim and bleak
Shure: 万能青年旅店
Shure: Omnipotent Youth Hostel
Shure: 简称万青
Shure: Abbreviated as "Wan Qing"
Katrina: 这我也听过这我也听过
Katrina: I've heard of this, I've heard of this too
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Shure: 比较有名的乐队
Shure: A pretty famous band
Shure: 万青
Shure: Wan Qing
Shure: 犹抱琵琶半遮面
Shure: Half concealing the pipa
Shure: 锦瑟无端五十弦
Shure: The unwarranted fifty strings of the brocade zither
Shure: 一弦一柱思华年
Shure: Each string, each column, thinking of the past years
Shure: 庄生晓梦迷蝴蝶
Shure: Zhuang Zhou's butterfly dream
Shure: 这什么什么诗来着
Shure: What poem is this again?
Katrina: 锦瑟
Katrina: "Brocade Zither"
Katrina: 让我再看你一遍
Katrina: Let me see you again
Katrina: 从南到北
Katrina: From south to north
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 我要找安河桥
Shure: I want to find Anhe Bridge
Katrina: 你去过安河桥没有
Katrina: Have you been to Anhe Bridge?
Shure: 安河桥北是吧
Shure: Anhe Bridge North, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Shure: 我应该在那换乘吧
Shure: I should transfer there, right?
Shure: 庄生晓梦迷蝴蝶让我再看你一眼
Shure: Zhuang Zhou's butterfly dream, let me see you again
Katrina: 庄生晓梦迷蝴蝶从南到北
Katrina: Zhuang Zhou's butterfly dream, from south to north
Shure: 庄生晓梦迷蝴蝶从南到北
Shure: Zhuang Zhou's butterfly dream, from south to north
Katrina: 庄生晓梦迷蝴蝶像是被五环路
Katrina: Zhuang Zhou's butterfly dream, like being on the Fifth Ring Road
Shure: （歌词）让我再看你一眼
Shure: (Lyrics) Let me see you again
Shure: （歌词）从南到北
Shure: (Lyrics) From south to north
Katrina: 天呐好久没有听到鸡叫
Katrina: Oh my gosh, haven't heard a rooster crow in a long time
Shure: （歌词）让我再看你一眼
Shure: (Lyrics) Let me see you again
Shure: （歌词）从南到北
Shure: (Lyrics) From south to north
Shure: （歌词）像是飞五环路
Shure: (Lyrics) Like flying on the Fifth Ring Road
Shure: （歌词）蒙蒙蒙住蒙住的双眼
Shure: (Lyrics) Covering, covering my eyes
Shure: （歌词）请你再想
Shure: (Lyrics) Please think again
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 不行了我绷不住了
Shure: I can't hold it any longer
Katrina: （歌词）是被五环路
Katrina: (Lyrics) Like being on the Fifth Ring Road
Shure: 哒哒啦哒哒啦哒
Shure: Da da la da da la da
Shure: 哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒
Shure: Da da da da da da da da
Katrina: 天每次做这种手工
Katrina: Oh man, every time I do this kind of craft
Katrina: 感觉自己的那个手脚巨不协调
Katrina: I feel like my hands and feet are so uncoordinated
Katrina: 看我的手指
Katrina: Look at my fingers
Katrina: 好不习惯
Katrina: I'm so not used to it
Shure: 砍了
Shure: Chop it off
Katrina: 什么卡子
Katrina: What? Chop what?
Shure: 手脚砍了
Shure: Chop off your hands and feet
Shure: 自由制造啊
Shure: It's all about free creation
Shure: 来我们刷刷我们北邮的这个新视频
Shure: Let's check out the new video from our university
Katrina: 有文创店海淀的吗
Katrina: Is there a cultural and creative shop in Haidian?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Katrina: 现在去你们学校玩两天
Katrina: I'm going to your school for two days now
Katrina: 玩20分钟就能玩完
Katrina: It only takes 20 minutes to see everything
Shure: 我操这不是旭书记吗
Shure: Damn, isn't that Secretary Xu?
Shure: 你看看书一讲话
Shure: Look at him, as soon as he speaks
Shure: 啪啪啪这闪光灯就上来了
Shure: Snap snap, the flashlights come out
Shure: 我跟你讲哎
Shure: I'm telling you
Shure: 关于我的学习
Shure: About my studies
Katrina: 燃起来了突然
Katrina: Suddenly feeling motivated
Shure: （歌词）亲爱的人哦
Shure: (Lyrics) Dear person, oh
Shure: 听过这个歌吗
Shure: Have you heard this song?
Shure: 亲密爱人
Shure: Intimate Lover
Katrina: 听过
Katrina: Yes, I have
Katrina: 我感觉我听的也挺杂的
Katrina: I feel like I listen to a lot of mixed stuff
Katrina: 我什么都听
Katrina: I listen to everything
Shure: 梅艳芳
Shure: Anita Mui
Shure: （歌词）今夜还吹
Shure: (Lyrics) Tonight, the wind blows
Shure: （歌词）今也吹着风
Shure: (Lyrics) Tonight, the wind still blows
Shure: （歌词）想起你好温柔
Shure: (Lyrics) Thinking of you, so gentle
Shure: （歌词）有你的日子
Shure: (Lyrics) The days with you
Shure: （歌词）分外的轻松
Shure: (Lyrics) Are especially relaxing
Shure: （歌词）也不是无影踪
Shure: (Lyrics) Not entirely without a trace
Shure: （歌词）只是只是想你太浓
Shure: (Lyrics) It's just, just that I miss you too much
Shure: （歌词）怎么会无时无刻把你梦
Shure: (Lyrics) How could I dream of you constantly
Shure: （歌词）爱的路上有你我并
Shure: (Lyrics) On the road of love, with you by my side
Shure: （歌词）寂寞你对我那么的好
Shure: (Lyrics) Loneliness, you treat me so well
Shure: （歌词）其实分外轻松
Shure: (Lyrics) Actually, it's especially relaxing
Shure: 是不是应该写会论文
Shure: Should I be writing my thesis now?
Katrina: 不去打扫卫生吧
Katrina: How about we clean up?
Shure: 写论文
Shure: Write my paper.
Katrina: 今天下午人家要来
Katrina: Someone's coming over this afternoon.
Katrina: 哎脏成那个样子
Katrina: Ugh, it's so dirty.
Katrina: 真能忍
Katrina: How can you stand it?
Katrina: 不行
Katrina: No way.
Katrina: 大扫除
Katrina: We need a thorough cleaning.
Shure: 要把我的房间收拾干净
Shure: You have to clean my room too.
Katrina: 不行
Katrina: No way.
Katrina: 这是一个严肃的问题
Katrina: This is a serious issue.
Shure: （歌词）如果感到悲伤
Shure: (Lyrics) If you feel sad,
Shure: （歌词）我会陪你晒太阳
Shure: (Lyrics) I'll bask in the sun with you.
Shure: （歌词）哦你听过那个young for you吗
Shure: (Lyrics) Oh, have you heard "Young For You"?
Katrina: 听过
Katrina: Yeah, I have.
Katrina: 之前高中可唱
Katrina: We used to sing it in high school.
Katrina: 高中可喜欢听这首
Katrina: Loved listening to it in high school.
Shure: 高中什么
Shure: High school what?
Katrina: 可喜欢听这首歌
Katrina: Loved listening to that song.
Shure: oh sunday's coming wanna drive my car to your apartment
Shure: Oh, Sunday's coming, wanna drive my car to your apartment.